the game uh hugging all your former
teammates but big surprise huh to a lot
of people
well honestly talking about me and uh
all the relationships i have with every
teammate
of mine we get to see it every single
game that uh
i got some great people out here but but
honestly it looked like it was a special
game for you and you
simply weren't going to let the nets
lose does this one mean a little more to
you
when you're going against guys you know
that well
i know a lot of people in the league
well i mean it's my former team
obviously
um you know i think i i let kind of
the the the casual nba fans talk about
it what it could mean in terms of
special night i'm just waiting for
you know the main stage going on and
playing in front of you know millions of
people and it actually mattering
uh in terms of winner win or lose and
win or lose will go home so i'm looking
forward to that but
games like this in in the middle of the
season where you go against guys that
you've known
well and um you know it's always a
blessing i'm always happy for those guys
and
you know i want to see them do well and
when we're playing against each other
we're just going to leave it out there
on the floor
and that's just where it stands we have
that respect um but of course our
relationships go way further off the
floor